ma vie en réalité de magali bertin là
depuis depuis le début de l'été on peut
vous suivre sur la chaîne youtube de
barbarie ça et ont reçu dans votre
quotidien
oui on sait absolument tout actuellement
tout odudu tout ça va j'essaie quelle
image je vous ai fait d'avoir un petit
résumé un petit compotée pour voir à
quoi ça ressemble regardez magal est en
réalité c'est comme sur le plateau mais
en réalité la vie en réalité de magali
bernat c'est la nouvelle télé réalité
qui suit la patronne des candidats donc
le quotidien incroyable avec cette
émission vous allez découvrir le
quotidien incroyable de cette femme
d'exception
une série qui la suit vraiment partout
même chez son dentiste du coup magali
berba est vraiment bien mises en valeur
[Musique]
on s'est rendu compte que magali passer
sa journée au téléphone
lui-même chute dentiste
un bourreau stagiaires apprennent très
cher mais bon jour
enchantée en tout cas cette série n'a
rien à envier à 24 heures chrono ou
urgences avec des teasers vraiment
haletant dans le prochain épisode vous
allez savoir ce qu'est lisabeth annoncé
à magali jenny énorme renvoi en une mini
série vu près de 270 mille fois sur
youtube avec un épisode chaque semaine à
la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous aimez vous n'aimez pas
mal mais en réalité je fais une
parenthèse bravo star trek pour le
pauvre 25000 exemplaires vendus alors
j'ai alors parce que vraiment j'ai reçu
des messages par rapport à ce livre
extraordinaire des gens et ça marche
alors elle avoue l'avons montré
absolument tout le dentiste le médecin y
va sans dire va pas je vais dire sans et
chez vous aussi vous avez chez vous est
pas encore mais est ce qu'on verra chez
vous oui on verra votre mari
ce genre à part moi chérie je t'aime
suis désolé je suis pas rentré ce soir
mais dans ce qui est sympa et je
comprends le succès de cette série c'est
que elle connaît bien les codes de la
téléréalité forcément elle connaît bien
les codes de ce qu'ils peuvent plaire un
public à son public qui la suit et c'est
très bien fait ça c'est de reconnaître
qu'il est destiné à son public et en
ville ta vie qui fait rêver beaucoup de
jeunes filles faut dire du tout on
découvre quelque chose de nouveaux
agents de stars dans l'univers des
placements de produits
c'est un programme sans prétention seul
bémol la voix off qui ont fait quand
même beaucoup avec des codes de serre
élevé chez magali c'est globalement tous
les élus santé après ça effectivement
gros succès près de 200000 vu par
épisode pour peu de communication c'est
bien ça alors allez-y doucement et
pagani quand même une embellie attaque
si je n'aime pas c'est pas je n'aime pas
contre vous en fait c'est un je n'aime
pas contre la télé réalité je suis
fatigué mais c'est une espèce de j'ai
fait un télé crochet j'ai gagné un télé
crochet où on se levait la star ac
on était inquiète sur les deux attendait
ce soit bien clair
jamais de ma vie je pourrais cracher
dans la soupe des ados ça par contre
j'aime y fait exceptionnel ce qui me
gêne aujourd'hui c'est
l'intellectualisation des choses dont
tous se fout moi je ça me fait pas
plaisir d'aller vous voir le matin chez
le dentiste etc vous non acquises année
mais ce qui marche de la vie des gens
c'est du voyeurisme ça marche à l'époque
à venir de fonction car ce n'est
l'intérêt nous touche ce qui est
vraiment une touche et je comprends pas
cheval jeux verts et du coup je vais me
mettre à la série est ce que je
comprends pas c'est pourquoi est-ce que
vous parlez pas de ce qui moi me touche
c'est à dire votre enfance j'aurais
envie que les gens ils attaquent
je te la mets je sais mais je sais mais
c'est pour ça je voudrais que vous
parliez de ça je voudrais vous parler de
lui mais le quotidien je peux pas passer
mon quotidien et je viens d'écrire à
raconter mon enfance parce que je les
fais déjà
et franchement ça a été bien accueillie
j'ai eu des super bonne crime et je
trouve ça fantastique mais je fais pas
radoter ça toute ma vie en fait les gens
ils ont envie de voir autre chose aussi
est bonne chose de voir l'envers du
décor quoique lente mais on a envie de
voir les coulisses son côté à 100 mais
je me limite à rien parce que justement
il n'y a aucune limite dans ce qu'on
montre et font jusqu'au bal se désole
quelques limites
pardon je l'entends non mais ce qui me
gêne ce qui me gêne rentrer dans
l'intimité
ce qui me gêne aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
parle simplement et pour une habile à
pour pour des gens comme deux doigts il
ya des il ya aussi des centaines
d'autres personnes qui souffrent dont on
parle jamais et ça ça m'énerve ça
m'énerve qu'on fasse croire à tous ces
jeunes qui regardent la télé que c'est
tout beau c'est tout rose c'est des
conneries des leur explique qu'on veut
c'est des conneries ce que tu fais quoi
en permanence